the question of nature and nurture is I
wouldn't call it settled but I would put
it like this we are all born with a
genetic inheritance and that genetic
inheritance sets boundaries on what we
might become it they guide us in the
sense of establishing about one quarter
of the variation of what we might become
and that when it comes to intelligence
or personality it's some minority of
what we could become and then against
that genetic background then our
genetics and environment the experiences
that we have and the nutrition that we
get interact with one another and that
then shapes us over the course of
childhood and a lifetime and so most of
the variation is so most of the
variation turns out to be believed to be
environmentally induced or you know
based on experience and so it's some
interplay between the two that makes us
who we are
one thing that's interesting about child
development is that so much of it there
are so many changes that take place in
children's brains not only from birth to
the age of six is when people think of
brain change but also even through
childhood and into adolescence so one
thing that probably does not help is
passive experiences for the child and
the classic example of this is the
Mozart myth the idea that playing Mozart
or the classical music to a baby will
make the child smarter what seems to be
important is active engagement so for
instance learning to play a musical
instrument is associated with improved
spatial reasoning and that seems to be
something that really helps a lot
another thing that helps is talking to
children it's been shown that there's a
positive relationship between the the
number of words a child hears per day
and IQ scores and this is true even when
you correct for socioeconomic status and
so just simply speaking to a child
playing with her talking with her that
kind of cognitive stimulation seems to
have a lasting positive effect on the
child's development and that's something
that that I think any parent can and
should do
well it's certainly the case that some
people who are called geniuses have the
ability to link unconnected ideas in
ways that other people can't see but one
important fact of that that's sort of I
would call that isn't so romantic is
this idea that Gladwell talks about
which is just the hard work of having
all that information on hand and
developing expertise through thousands
and thousands of hours of practice we
talked earlier about Google making us
dumber well look if Google removes the
need for us to have all that knowledge
on hand and then that removes us from us
the ability to have these facts in our
heads on hand and so I think that this
is one area where we can think about
something that maybe gets lost a little
bit right geniuses are people who are in
many cases are people who have a lot of
information directly at their at their
beck and call and they think about it
and they start putting it together so
you know one component of genius is
sticking together things in unexpected
ways
but another component is having those
things to stick together right and I
think that there's a element of truth to
this idea of thousands of hours of
practice making a creative scientist or
artist or writer or whatever it is that
we may care in ecology Gnaeus
so one thing I've experienced at
Princeton is that public spaces where my
colleagues and I are likely to cross
paths are excellent places to to share
ideas and have discussions that rise up
spontaneously and at our campus the
genomics Institute is a newish building
that it has an atrium where we run
across one another and we have lunch or
coffee or what have you and that seems
to be a place where there's a lot of
ferment both socially and also
intellectually I repeatedly have
meetings there and so I think one
principle that comes up in modern design
for instance in scientific buildings is
creating spaces where people can cross
paths and I think that's an incredibly
important aspect of creating of spaces
where creativity is fostered and it's
some it's a real live version of
Facebook or Google and as much as people
like to talk about those social
networking sites personal networking
between live people face-to-face is
still far more effective than any kind
of online interaction